well the Latino population continues to
grow across our community and the need
for more experiences specifically for
Latinos is growing as well a new hotel
casino will open up very soon on
Cheyenne and the 15 8 news now reporter
Ryan Matthey shows us what's in the
works
[Music]
a Rebrand with a Latin Flair
[Applause]
the long-standing lucky Club Hotel and
Casino in North Las Vegas breaking
ground on a Rebrand for its surrounding
Community that's over 40 percent Latino
and for a decade and a half we learned
Fifth Street gaming CEO Seth Shore says
this will be the nation's first Latino
hotel and casino after acquiring the
property 15 years ago Hotel Jefe as
it'll be called partnering with Ojos
local sports Cantina a chain across
Texas New Mexico and Arizona for
authentic drinking and dining
in the back a tequila Garden inside a
high-end Latino nightclub and upstairs
90 fully renovated rooms in close
proximity to the I-15 for those just
passing through or sticking around city
councilwoman Pamela goins-brown says
it's much needed in North Las Vegas it's
celebrating cultures people ethnicities
different people differences and
likenesses and like I said we are such a
diverse community and it just feels
right to do something like that it's
what the owner calls avoid in the local
market especially in an area with a
dense Latino population but the
questions are how authentic will it
really be and is it what the community
really wants and it's been 15 years in
the waiting Albert Delgado with the
Latin chamber expecting the property to
be received well we also see that as uh
as an owner that wants to service the
Latino Community more of a passion to do
so than probably a cash grab if you want
to call that this is something that
we've nurtured and we've done in a
collaborative of way for a very very
long time so it's a combination of
understanding that audience but we're
actually bringing them things that just
simply don't exist here today
well the property shuts down Monday for
the months-long remodel now their plan
is to reopen in mid-January with rates
nearly half of what customers would pay
on average at other hotels across the
valley